intense fighting around the town of
solidar in eastern Ukraine Russian
military advances are being claimed and
denied why have both sides battle so
fiercely over this area and does it Mark
a new phase in the war this is Inside
Story
[Music]
hello and welcome to the program I'm
fully batibo Ukraine has refuted Russian
claims it's captured the Eastern town of
solidar whatever the truth fighting has
been intense around what is Europe's
largest salt mine nearly all of the
small towns 11 000 inhabitants have left
and almost everything above ground is
destroyed so why has this battle been so
Fierce and does it signal a change in
how this war is being fought we'll be
discussing this and more with our guests
in just a few minutes but first two
reports from Ukraine and Russia Ali
Hashem in Moscow explains this battle's
connection to a different one within
Russia's establishment before that we
hear from Charles Stratford who spent
her day with Ukrainian special forces in
bakmut close to soledar
Ukrainian defensive positions west of
the Frontline city of bakmut
Russian infantry are slowly advancing
into Northern and Eastern residential
areas over the hill
the center of town is almost completely
destroyed
streets are virtually deserted the
blasts of exploding artillery and
Rockets is almost constant
a soldier with the Ukrainian Special
Forces leads us to their bunker
warm dark tunnels lined with weapons and
ammunition boxes
drones feed real-time video of Russian
infantry movement only a kilometer and a
half away
they have a lot of Manpower so they sent
every time their troops like a waves so
we cannot stop every time because we
have less guys and unfortunately we also
lost a lot of guys at this moment
men rest before their next mission often
close combat where trenches are only 20
meters apart
commanders insist we hide their
identities and don't film landmarks
nearby that could give their positions
away
they split into small groups in order to
avoid our artillery and they infiltrate
through residential areas and tree lines
but they also suffer huge casualties
Military Intelligence from our Western
Partners is often not distributed to us
quickly enough on the front lines where
we need it to Target command centers
Logistics hubs and weapons depots
the shelling is getting closer
it's been an intensive occasion of
shelling in the last few minutes the
soldiers here are telling us that up to
600 Russian soldiers are moving into new
positions in the northeast of the city
we climb the stairs of a destroyed
Residential Building smoke rises from
fresh strikes a few streets away close
to Russian Hill sections of town
what remains of the lives of people who
fled the fighting lies abandoned in a
destroyed home
Russian forces are gradually surrounding
Bahamut from solidar around 15
kilometers to the north
to villages in the Southeast
strangling what little remains of life
here as the Ukrainian Army prepared new
lines of Defense Charles Strafford Al
Jazeera
it's a moment Moscow has been waiting
for
the capture of solidar became possible
thanks to the continuous strikes on the
positions of the Armed Forces of Ukraine
by Russian Air Force missiles and
artillery
Moscow hopes solidar will be a stepping
stone to another strategic Ukrainian
City
I think that only after the liberation
of bhakmot will an offensive operation
be prepared to help complete the
liberation of Donetsk from Ukraine
solidar opens the way for Russian
military units to chromatosk this is the
largest city of the Donetsk People's
Republic still held by Ukrainian
nationalists
but there's another battle going on this
one inside the Russian establishment
over the Royal mercenaries from the
Wagner group played in capturing solidar
the group hosted on its telegram Channel
a statement in the form of an answered
question accusing some officials of
trying to steal its Victory while
stressing that the only Fighters present
in the battle for solidar were Wagner
Fighters
the ministry of Defense later issued a
statement confirming that Wagner's role
was essential in the battle for solidar
Wagner is not registered in Russia we do
not have a law on private military
companies therefore apparently the
military is trying not to mention Wagner
as part of the group that performs the
tasks of the special military operation
of course this is very insulting to the
Wagner Fighters and the case is also
about the jealousy of some generals
and as Russia attempts to capture more
cities The Echoes of the battle in
Moscow for the heart and mind of
Vladimir Putin may be heard in the
battlefields in Ukraine Al Jazeera
Moscow foreign
for today's show from Odessa in Ukraine
Michael borser q he is a senior fellow
at the Atlantic Council from Moscow
Sergey Markov who's the director of The
Institute of political studies and a
former spokesman for President Vladimir
Putin and from Bath Patrick bury a
senior defense and security lecturer at
the University of bath and a former
British army officer and former NATO
analyst thank you gentlemen for being
with us on Inside Story welcome Michael
let me start with you in Odessa if I can
the Ukrainian government disputes the
claim that the Russians are in control
of solidar how big of a setback would it
be for Ukraine if the Russians indeed
were in control of this Salt Town
right well first of all the Russians are
making this much more of a bigger deal
than it is um the um the status of
solidar is still very very much up in
the air how do we know that from
correspondents who are there on the
front line and from uh Ukrainian
servicemen who have given comments to
foreign media I think from the Russian
side solidar has much more informational
or propaganda value than actual
strategic value
after humiliating losses on the
battlefield included including losing
katason they need some type of wind no
matter how small to be able to feed to
their Russian public and especially to
those um warhawks to those Russian
bloggers who are giving actually the
common a tough time now the Ukrainian
side it should be said that um you know
they don't uh look at this war as a
human meat grinder like the Russians do
when there are threats to to their men
and women they do pull back a bit and
they've made that clear because human
life unlike on the Russian side they say
is to be valued one last thing if I may
on this is that it is a very very long
front line it tends to move perhaps 50
or a few hundred meters one way the
other day by day so there's a long way
to go before uh anyone can claim having
taken over solidar all right let's ask
Sergey in Moscow why solidar is such a
big deal for Russia why has so much
Manpower including mercenaries Sergey
been brought on to this area
Senate are not important for Russia
first of all we should uh we should
understand Russian government is saying
the truth keep repressive regime is
lying almost all the time
and solidar not important from military
point of view it just it is not
important for the military point of view
why are they sending so many troops into
into solidar including mercenaries from
the Wagner group
is very important politically first of
all for uh vladimironsky because a real
military capacity of Ukrainian Army is
created not by Ukraine but by help of uh
Western countries but Western countries
want to give help to the successful
Ukrainian Army that's why it's a very
important politically for Vladimir Putin
to show that Ukrainian Army is still
going forward and uh losing of city
after a big battle it's a bigger a fail
a political failure or college
in the face of his Western Partners
that's why zelensky sent a dozens of
thousands of Ukrainian soldiers to fight
for the such small cities uh as salidar
and Batman and ready to rule uh doesn't
talk for thousands of Ukrainian soldiers
to die for this
small cities which politically means
almost military
means almost nothing but politically
it's very important for uh serious
things because it's important is
becoming important for uh those who want
to crush the landscape Russia let's
bring in uh Patrick Berry in bath for
your thoughts on this about the
significance of solidar and back mode
some say solidar as uh Sergey was saying
there is of no significance militarily
to Russia it's more related to Russian
domestic politics what are your thoughts
on on this battle and how it's unfolding
yeah I'd agree with sir guy and actually
Michael is saying the same thing too
look the um the key thing is here look
at the the the noises coming out of the
Kremlin and the um the the videos being
trying to flood the internet from the
Wagner group there's obviously serious
Discord
um amongst there we know some about the
power struggles between uh garasimov uh
the general in charge now of the whole
operation uh pregos in uh sirovakin
um and and it seems to be that
essentially this is about they're not
fighting a a battle in the way that you
would over a strategic objective this is
about sending Russian troops into a meat
grinder to be killed to meet some sort
of political infighting uh about the
about the conduct of the War and who
should be the head honcho on the ground
so that's my reading of it essentially I
think
um look once once once um both sides
start to take a serious amount of
casualties insignificant objectives can
become more significant because there's
a blood
um the there's a there's a basically a
blood treasure which has been spent and
it becomes more significant but I still
think
um that this solid art really doesn't
matter
um significantly even if you zoom the
map out over backwards it doesn't matter
massively
um and I don't agree with the idea that
this is a big big issue for zielinski in
terms of uh NATO support NATO as we know
is a defensive organization if Ukraine
will start to lose city after City then
NATO would actually up up its uh support
I'd imagine so
um I don't think really it has an
optical or a a heavy way on on NATO
allies and it's also interesting to note
that the UK has just said it's going to
send a challenger two tanks to Ukraine
so watch this space India let's let's
allow Sega to respond to that seggy
Patrick says you know Russia is fighting
for politics here for political
infighting rather than a strategic clear
plan when it comes to Soledad and back
mode what is your response to that
for domestic politics is absolutely no
needless to think to say accelerator
because Vladimir Putin popularity very
high and also uh military uh uh Power of
Russia uh fully depend on Russian
capacities Russian society and Russian
economy so for Russian domestic politics
it's not so important of course the
Russian Society want uh very much a
Russian army to go forward and to
liberate more and more uh Ukraine cities
not only Daniels but also
a Russian representative United Nations
say very clearly last night about
Russian demands Russia demands that uh
there should be no threat to Russian
security upon the Ukrainian territory
and also that all russian-speaking
people uh should have political and
social rights uh in the uh Ukrainian
territory as well if it will be by by
piece by negotiation Russia will be
happy to do it but if Western Country
will continue to insist that
russian-speaking people should be second
kind of the citizens with no right to
speak a native language Russia will get
their goals uh bypass all right let's
bring in Michael in Ukraine to respond
to that we heard there from Sergey
Russia's end games in his uh when it
comes to this war in Ukraine Ukraine's
end game in this conflict is the
restoration of its territory to pre-2014
borders I want to know Michael whether
you know the Russians are becoming a
more formidable Force right now for the
ukrainians on the ground in Close
Quarter uh fighting with more you know
as we've heard Wagner group mercenaries
involved in the conflict how difficult
is it for Ukraine to defend its
positions right now yeah well first of
all uh what's coming out of circus
malta's complete nonsense
um if indeed the Russians care to one
iota about the security the protection
of Russian speakers here in Ukraine why
are Russians speaking cities being
bombed like karakil for example like
other cities in Houston Ukraine I hear
from ukrainians who are Russian speakers
who come from that region they can't
understand the Russian mentality on this
but you know when we think about it the
Russians have put very low value on life
so that's why that's happening and in
terms of the Russian fighting strategy
you refer to well right now as I sit
here Ukraine is under a nationwide
missile attack right now from the
Russian side that's the only way they
know how to fight is not eye to eye
combat with with their opponent but with
these long-range missiles that are very
destructive so trying to weaponize uh
winter trying to damage Ukrainian
infrastructure I think um what we're
going to see going forward over the next
days and weeks is quite the pivot
probably from the Ukrainian side on the
front online and a big reason for that
fully will be because of the it'll take
some time but the addition of these
tanks like the Challenger 2 post Cold
War fourth generation tank
um and also the other uh fighting
Vehicles provided by Europe also the the
added training uh things like that but
one more thing quickly is I think
between now and uh the one year
anniversary in the middle of February
Russia will try to launch quite a
massive assault if we know their
mentality well enough okay let's allow
so I get to respond to that Sergey we
had heard Michael say there that the
Russians have a low value on life
they're using mercenaries made up of
former convicts and they don't really
care about uh losing these uh men on the
battlefield what do you respond to that
he'd just like
um
I think uh what we have now from
military defense Ministers of both
countries of course we cannot trust this
information during the war but according
to my evaluation uh my understanding for
Russian army uh citizens of Ukraine it's
our people
put many time told that we are one of
the people is some kind of Civic War
inside Russian people you may know that
as Michael said if Russia considers
these people there it's people why is it
bombing cities that are occupied by by
itself he's lying he's lying Russia
never targeting civilian neighborhoods
it's a city like a heart attack and
just a hundred percent
propaganda okay there's a lot of
physiologies Patrick
where's the Russian bombing concentrated
you know look that's alternative reality
we're talking about here so I don't know
how how we can continue to debate with
someone with an alternative reality you
know
um I I you know to come back to sergey's
first point is he well knows um just
because you're a Russian speaker doesn't
mean you make you any less Ukrainian
according to uh the referendum and all
the polling that was
um conducted you can be a Russian
speaker and now it's heavily diminishing
as you'd imagine and also feel
pro-ukrainian
um so of course there's some small
segments that the population that still
do feel Russian but it is smaller than
it was
um so I don't think that even that
argument holds if you're going to say
that the Russians haven't bombarded cave
and car here if I don't like I can't
have a debate with someone about that
it's clear to everybody okay um Let me
let me ask you Patrick about the recent
military shake-up we've seen in in
Russia uh and how how do you think it's
going to change the conflict this
military shake-up we've seen within the
Russian army and as uh General
garasimov's appointment do you think
Harold a new phase in the conflict
there's a few ways of looking at it um
and it's again again it's about internal
Dynamics was it is it that he is being
put in there because you broke it you
know you you just destroyed our pretty
much destroyed our conventional army
with a half brain plan for taking a
massive country uh and now you fix it
yeah uh or was sarovicin becoming too
powerful with a direct line to Putin and
therefore they moved in to get rid of
them uh I agree with Michael I think we
can expect to see you know a hundred
thousand
partly trained uh recently mobilized
Russian troops being
um you know pushed into an attack
somewhere and we'll have to see
hopefully the ukrainians can repel that
I wouldn't be surprised if they have to
give ground in places but really this is
about the summer of Ollie
um these tanks which hopefully come in
line the the British announcement is all
about pushing the Germans the Germans
need to get their finger out they've got
they're the ones with the leopard two
tanks there's lots of them in Europe the
Challenger two different Logistics
change they're in the UK it's it's a
gesture it's important gesture an
important gesture you say uh Patrick
what's the end game for the Western
arming Ukraine with more offensive
weapons we've heard the UK announcing
the tanks today France as well what is
the end game of the West here but so I
was just coming onto this so I think the
tanks and the armored infantry fighting
vehicles are about creating an armored
Brigade for Ukraine that can be used
come the summer in counter offenses I'd
expect two Ukrainian counter offensives
this summer is what I'm thinking who
knows how successful they'll be the
Russians have had a long time to prepare
defensive lines
um and there's a few things about Modern
Warfare we are waiting to find out such
as how to Precision guide and Munitions
work against
um uh trenches and and defenses in depth
uh which is different from we've seen
them so far so uh yeah it remains to be
seen but we've definitely got another
summer of fighting coming at least all
right so again Markov in Moscow we are
nearing the one-year anniversary
anniversary of this Russian invasion
what are Russians plans uh you know for
solidar and Beyond after it's
Consolidated its control of this area
a Russian plants steals the same Russia
doesn't need new territory you may know
from geography that Russia is the
biggest country in the world in terms of
uh territories and kilometers uh what
Russia needs is also called to liberate
people in Ukraine those uh Ukrainian
political leaders who believe that
Ukraine and Russia should be uh
internship and in one economic Union
should be liberated from Ukrainian
prisoners should be allowed to have a
free political campaigning for getting
political faction and the majority in
the Ukrainian Parliament it means that
Ukraine should be democratized and
Ukraine should be neutral it's what
Russian army is fighting Kapoor that's
why it's very much support from military
point of view I predict I agree with my
uh colleagues that is most of the
analysts expect that Russian army will
try to attempt to go forward in the end
of the winter and Ukrainian Army is
preparing by Western Masters to be ready
for the attacking against Russian army
in the middle of spring now is mass
mobilization Ukrainian in Ukraine and
also sending a lot of offensive
Weaponry to the Ukrainian Army so we
will see the result we believe that we
will win because uh for from our side is
true okay Michael in Ukraine there's
been a substantive change in the type of
Weaponry the U.S and its allies are
providing Ukraine how will this help and
how do you see the conflict evolving in
the next few months as we near the
one-year anniversary of the Russian
invasion
sure um I'll answer that but just
quickly to serger's point um it may be
geographically a big country in the
world but why is it that they have to
forcibly Deport hundreds of thousands of
Ukrainian children and women and men to
Russia uh why is it that they have to
set lines of Russian troops behind those
convicts fighting for a Wagner group and
others to shoot them if they start
running back from the Ukrainian front
lines that that would be a good question
for him to answer but I think in terms
of what we're going to see going forward
is there's a very big difference now um
in terms of Western support for
Ukraine's efforts I think the the
leaders in Western capitals have grown
the spine to send these main Battlefield
tanks and very heavy duty uh fighting
vehicles but also there's a realization
fully that this is no longer a war
limited to Ukraine Russian missiles have
violated moldovan airspace not far from
here by the way many times our missile
fragments have fallen into Poland plus
the knock-on effect of the migration of
the weaponization of food weaponization
of energy uh so to kind of my main point
here is that there's a realization in
these Western capitals that if Mr Putin
and his forces are not pushed back now
for good that Russia will attempt uh
grabs on Ukraine again and surrounding
territory and affect other NATO
countries as well so they should have
done it earlier there were a lot of
warnings but finally I think the tide
has turned and I don't think given the
rotten the Deep rotten corruption on the
Russian side they're having to mobilize
convicts homeless people that they have
much chance against what is awaiting
them right now okay gentlemen we will
leave it there unfortunately we are
running out of time thank you so very
much for a very interesting discussion
Michael berserk you Sergey Markov and
Patrick Berry thank you very much for
joining us and thank you too for
watching you can always watch this
program again anytime by visiting our
website at aljazeera.com for further
discussion go to our Facebook page
that's facebook.com forward slash AJ
Inside Story and of course you can join
the conversation on Twitter our handle
is at AJ inside story from me fully
batibo and the whole team here in Doha
thanks for watching bye for now